>> I JUST SIGNED THE
PROCLAMATION ON ASYLUM, VERY
IMPORTANT WANTED
IMPORTANT.WANTED
PEOPLE CAN COME IN BUT THEY
HAVE TO COME IN THROUGH THE
PORTS OF ENTRY.
>> Brian: GOOD THING THE
PRESIDENT STOPPED BEFORE HE
WENT TO PARIS HE HAD A LOT
TO SAY.
THE CARAVAN IS SNAKING
TOWARD THE U.S. BORDER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
RESPONDING AS YOU JUST HEARD
TO ITS APPROACH BY
TIGHTENING U.S. ASYLUM LAWS.
I'M VERY CURIOUS ABOUT THIS
TO SEE IF IT WILL WITHSTAND
THE TEST.
PROCLAMATION SIGNED THIS
MORNING THE PRESIDENT SAID
NOBODY CAUGHT ILLEGALLY
ENTERING THE U.S. WILL BE
ALLOWED TO CLAIM ASYLUM
AFTER THE FACT.
THEY WILL NEVER BE CITIZENS.
THE MOVE IS ALREADY FACING A
LEGAL CHALLENGE.
ARTHUR A FORMER IMMIGRATION
JUDGE AND FELLOW AT THE
STUDY FOR IMMIGRATION
STUDIES AND JOINS US NOW.
ANDREW, FIRST TELL ME WHAT
THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER WITH
THIS PROCLAMATION SAYS.
>> THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
ACTUALLY BARS THE ENTRY OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ENTERING
THE UNITED STATES ILLEGALLY
TO THE UNITED STATES.
HE IS USING HIS AUTHORITY
UNDER SECTION 212 F AND 215
A OF THE INA TO DO THAT.
>> Brian: IF YOU TRY TO
SNEAK IN AND GO AND CLAIM
ASYLUM IF YOU DON'T GO TO
THE PORT OF ENTRY, YOU ARE
NEVER GOING TO BE A CITIZEN.
SO YOU BETTER GO TO THE PORT
OF ENTRY.
AND YOU BETTER GO IN THE
RIGHT WAY.
AND THEN WE WILL HEAR WHAT
YOU HAVE TO SAY AND SEE IF
IT ADDS UP TO THE LEVEL THAT
WE ACCEPT YOU FOR ASYLUM,
RIGHT?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
AND WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
ATTEMPTING TO DO IS TO
CHANNEL EVERYBODY WHO HAS
WHAT'S CALLED A CREDIBLE
FEAR CLAIM THROUGH THOSE
PORTS OF ENTRY SO THEY CAN
ENTER IN AN ORDERLY AND
LEGAL FASHION RATHER THAN
SNEAKING ACROSS THE BORDER
WHERE WE HAVE TO USE OUR
BORDER PATROL AGENTS TO GO
OUT AND FIND THEM.
PUTS HUGE STRESS ON THE
16,000 BORDER PATROL AGENTS
WHO CONTROL THE 1900 MILES
OF THE BORDER EVERY DAY.
AND IT MAKES THE SYSTEM
BREAK DOWN.
QUITE FRANKLY, THIS IS THE
BEST POSSIBLE SOLUTION THAT
WE CAN HAVE, TO HAVE THOSE
PEOPLE GO THROUGH THE PORT
OF ENTRY.
ALSO GIVE THOSE PEOPLE
ENCOURAGEMENT TO APPLY IN A
THIRD COUNTRY, MEXICO, WHICH
IS AN ASYLUM GRANTING
COUNTRY AS WELL.
>> Brian: I READ THAT IN THE
LAST FISCAL YEAR 140,000
CENTRAL AND SOUTH AMERICANS
HAVE COME TO THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
SO IF YOU FERRY THEM TO THE
PORT OF ENTRY SOME WILL SAY
THIS TAKES FOREVER.
THE PROCESS IS GOING TO BE
SO LONG, WORD IS GOING TO
GET OUT THAT IT'S NOT EASY
TO GET IN THIS COUNTRY
ANYMORE AND IT WILL HAVE A
POSITIVE RIPPLE EFFECT.
THAT'S THE HOPE, CORRECT?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY THE HOPE.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE SEEING
ABOUT 2,000 PEOPLE A DAY WHO
ARE ADMISSIBLE INTO THE
UNITED STATES WHO ARE UNITED
STATES.
THAT'S BEFORE THE CARAVAN OF
INDIVIDUALS FROM THE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE COUNTRIES
OF EL SALVADOR, HONDURAS AND
GUATEMALA EVEN MAKE IT TO
THE UNITED STATES.
YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW MUCH
WORSE IT'S GOING TO BE ONCE
THEY DO ACTUALLY MAKE IT TO
THIS COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT'S IS
ATTEMPTING TO PROACTIVELY,
AGAIN, FUNNEL THOSE
INDIVIDUALS INTO THE PORTS
OF ENTRY WHERE THEY CAN BE
PROCESSED IN AN ORDERLY
FASHION.
>> Brian: DO IT THE RIGHT
WAY, WORK YOURSELF TOWARD
THE GREEN CARD AND MAKE THE
GREEN CARD CITIZENSHIP OR DO
IT THE WRONG WAY AND BLOW
IT.
YOU ARE NEVER GOING TO BE A
CITIZEN, THERE IS SOMETHING
SOMETHING CALLED SPARED FROM
DEPORTATION BY QUALIFYING
FOR A LESSER STATUS KNOWN
FOR REMOVAL.
THAT'S IN THE BYLAWS.
WE WILL SEE IF THIS CAN WITH
STABBED A LEGAL CHALLENGE.
YOU TOLD ME IN THE BREAK YOU
THINK THIS IS VERY CREATIVE
AND THIS IS A VERY
WELL-THOUGHT OUT PROVISION.
>> I REALLY THINK THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS HAD THE
EXPERIENCE OF HAVING HIS
OTHER EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND
PROCLAMATIONS SUBJECT TO
MANY LAYERS OF JUDICIAL
REVIEW.
I THINK THEY HAVE DONE A
VERY GOOD JOB OF CRAFTING
THIS ONE TO SUSTAIN THOSE
CHALLENGES.
>> Brian: THE ACLU WILL BE